[音楽]
[拍手]
皆さんこんにちは病院で哲学者として働い
ている錦城高ですその哲学者から皆さんに
質問があり
ます正しく生きるとはどういうこと
でしょうか正しく生きるために私たちは
どういう人になれば言いでしょうかその
答えは物語の中にあるの
です物語とは2つ以上の出来事を深く関連
付けてそこに意味を付与することすなわち
物語というのは意味の生成装置なの
ですプライドのですの背景に星空のあの背
を使ってるんですけれども実はこれは理由
がありまし
て物語というのは星座のようなものだと
言われてるんですね皆さんに質問です
けれどもこの星空の中にですね星座は存在
するでしょうか存在しないですよね存在し
てるのは星だけなんですしかしながら
私たちはその無数にある星の中からある
特定の星を選んでそしてそれらを心の目で
結びつけることによってそこに星座を見て
取ってるんです実は物語も全く同じなん
ですね無数にある過去の出来事の中から
ある特定の出来事を選んでそれらを
結びつけることによって私たちの側がそこ
に物語を引いてはそこに意味を見てとって
いるわけなんです私たちの側が物語意味を
見てとるからこそ物語は科学や物理学では
当て真似ができないような非常に柔軟な
仕方で私たちの人生の様々な経験に意味を
付与することができるのです物語には3つ
の特徴があると言われてます事後的一時的
共同的です物語の1つ目の特徴それはです
ね事後的であるということです皆さんよく
過去は変わると聞きますよねこれは本当の
ことなんですしかしながらこれはですね
過去の出来事そのものが変わるわけでは
ない過去の出来事をですね私たちが
振り返った時どういう風に結びつけるかに
よってその過去から未来にかけての私たち
の経験の意味が事後的に変わってくるねと
いうことなるわけです物語の2つ目の特徴
それは一時的ですよく学生さんがねえ先生
自分探せる旅に出ますって言うんですよね
そういう時私は学生さんにねいやいや
そんな本当の自分なんてないよって言うん
ですねその代わりに私が学生さんに言うの
はですね今日あなたが誰かに語るあなたの
物語それがあなた自身なんですよという風
に私は言うんですねということは私たち
自身というのはですね誰かに語ることに
よってどんどん変わっいく非常に不安定な
存在ということになるわけなんですねで不
安定な存在だからこそ私たちは自分自身を
一時的に停止してそしてですね物語という
形式で部分的にですね切り取ってそして
それを語ることによって一時的に部分的に
自分を理解してるっていうことになるわけ
なんです3つ目の物語の特徴それは共同的
です私たちは自分の物語のみならず他者の
物語も一緒に向いでるわけなんですね
語り手と聞き手の間に物語があります
そして物語がですね語りと慶長を返して
変換と循環を返して行ったり来たりして
いる中でその物語が変容していきます変容
していく中でその意味がですね新たに付与
されていく意味がどんどん変わっていく
そういう機械場空間それが物語の共同著作
ということになるわけです私たちが物語を
1人でつくとどうしてもですねそのの物語
っていうのは1人ありになったりとか自己
正当化的になったりとかま暴走しがちです
よねしかしながら物語を他者と共に紡ぐと
ですねその物語はえ独りではないより
バランスの取れたものになりますさらに
物語を共同著作することによって互いに
ですねあなたはそれでいいんですよとね
承認し合うことによって私たちはですね
互いに助け合うことができる前を向いて
ですね生きていくことができるわけなん
ですでこの証人に関してですね皆さんに
紹介したい言葉がありますそれがランクル
ナサという言葉なんですねこの言葉私の
故郷の言葉なんですけれども少々誤解され
てる言葉なんですねどういう風に誤解され
てるかというとま沖縄のですね定型文化
適当文化を表す言葉として理解されてる
実際に沖縄の人もそういう風に使ってる
ところあるんですねしかしながらそれは
本当の正しい使い方ではないんですね
正しい使い方っていうのは実はですねこの
ランクルナイサーの前にマトゥ早計って
いうね窃盗がつくんですでこれでワン
セットの言葉だったんですねところがま
後ろだけが1人歩きしてしまったってこと
になるわけですじゃあ意味は何かって言と
マトゥていうのはマ早計っていうのはそれ
をするという意味ですすなわち人として
正しいことをしていれば後はなんとかなる
さ真面目でひき真摯であればあはなんとか
なるさっていうのがまナクル内装の本当の
意味だったわけなんですねしかもこの
ナクルナさにはルールがあるんですそれは
ですね自分で使ってはいけないってことな
んですね本当に頑張ってるということを
知っている周りの人がその頑張っている人
にかけてあげる言葉それがナンクルナイサ
とことなるすなわちナクル年祭というのは
自己皇帝自己証人ではなく過去皇帝他者に
よる証人の言葉になるわけなんですね
苦しいこと悲しいことを受け入れくじけず
に人として誠実に正しく生きる道を選ぶ
ならばその後はきっとうまくいくと信じて
生きるまこういうの人のですね姿勢生き方
これがナンクルナイサーの意味だったわけ
ですねでここでね正しく生き
るっていうことがありますけれどもこれを
もうちょっと詳しくですね考えていきたい
と思います皆さん正しく生きるとはどう
いうことでしょうかそれは正しいことを
するということでしょうかあるいは正しい
人になるということでしょうかまそうかも
しれないんですけれども私はちょっと違う
考え方をしてるんですね正しく生きるとは
ですねあなたは何者かと自分に向き合う
ことだと思うんですねまとかく倫理とは
ですね今何をなすべきかという行為に焦点
あてがちですよねでももっと大事なのは
その行為をするあなたは何ものかあなたは
何を大切にし何を目指してるのか私たちは
どう生きたいのかどう生きるべきなのか
そして私たちはどういう人になりたいのか
どういう人になるべきなのかまこういう
ことをですね考えることがとても大事な
わけなんですさあそこでですねこのどう
いう人になるべきかっていうことをもう
少し深く考えていきたいと思います少し私
の話をさせてください皆さん誕生日って
どういう日だと思いますか誕生日とはです
ね他の人から祝ってもらう日じゃないん
ですよ誕生日というのはですね私たちの
両親に対して産んでくれたこと育てくれた
ことを感謝する日だと思うんですよね
お父さんお母さんがいたからこそ今の自分
がいるこういうですね最強の物語を語る日
それが誕生日だと思うですですねで私の
誕生日11月10日なんですけれどもこの
2020年の11月10日っていうのは
ですね私にとっては忘れられない誕生日な
んですねなぜならえ2年間ですね難病で病
生活をしていた私の最愛の母がですね20
数年以上ですね暮らした山を降りて最後の
入院をした日だったからなんですで前日の
9日にですねま電話がかかってきましたね
高調子が悪いよとねえこれはあの大変な
ことになったと思ってですすぐにね山に
向かいましたそうするとね私の母はとても
苦しそうでしたねですぐにですね入院した
方がいいんじゃないかと思ったんです
けれどもでもそこで私は思いとまったん
ですねもし今ですね母が山を降りると母は
もう2度とこの山に帰って来ないかもしれ
ないせめてあと1晩母が愛して病まない
この山でね最後の夜を過ごさせてあげたい
まそういう風に思ったんですねそしてあの
母と相談してですね次の日の朝え入院する
ことに決めましたで次の日の朝ですねえま
入院の準備をしている私にですね母がこう
いう風に言うわけですよ高野の誕生日なの
にごめんねとま誕生日というのはですね母
に感謝をする日だと思っていたのでまさか
その日にですね母から謝られるとは夢にも
思っていませんでした返す言葉もなくです
ね私はただただえ入院の準備をしたのを
覚えてますいよいよ山を降りる時が来まし
た山を降りながらですね母は黙って流れて
いく山の風景を見ています言葉にはしませ
んでしたがこれが最後だということは母も
私も分かっていましたこの23年以上ね何
回も何回も生きしたこの山の風景を眺め
ながらその時母が何を思ったのか私は知る
よしもありませんでした入院してからです
ね落ち着きを取り戻した母はですねまここ
に来るともう一度山へ帰れる気がしてき
たってね笑顔を見せてくれたんですよね
本当にですねもう1度母をね山に返して
あげたいなと思いましたましかしながら
ですね母は12日後の11月22日に静か
に旅立ちました私たちが人生で直面し
なければならない最大の困難それはですね
愛する人の喪失だと思うんですよねこの
愛する人の喪失に向き合いそしてその喪失
と共に生きていくためには私たちにには
個人の助けが必要なのですすなわち個人は
ですねこの共同著作を通して私たちの背中
をそっと押してくれる私たちにが前を向い
て生きていく力を与えてくれるわけなん
です私もそうだったんですねあの母が何度
もですね生き生きした山道をですね今度は
ですね私が山を管理するためにですね生き
しそしてですね母と共同著作をですねし
続けることによって今度はいつか将来です
よ私自身があの山をですね降りる時最後に
ね降りる時に母があの日何を思ったか必ず
分かる日が来るかもしれ
ないいつか私がですね息を引き取る時母の
人生には意味があったなぜなら自分は母が
命をかけてですね守ってきた残してくれた
山の畑のおかげでこんなにも素晴らしい
人生を遅れたのだからというですね物語を
いつか語れることができるかもしれないま
そういうですね物語が語れることが来る日
をね待ち望みつつ希望しつつですね私は
これからも母の山に向かう選択をしていき
たいと思い
ますまもしかするとですね今この話を聞い
てくださってる人々の中にはですね現在
大変困難な出来事にですね直面してる人
いるかもしれませんましかしながらその
方々にお伝えしたいのはねその困難な
出来事の意味はね今はまだわからないん
ですねしかしながらいつかある日ですね
その時ねその意味が分かる時が来るかも
しれないいつか将来この出来事を振り返っ
た時にあの出来事があったからこそ今の
自分があるとそういう物語を事後的に語る
日が来るかもしれないね物語こそが私たち
の希望より所最後の砦なのですそしてこの
最後の希望砦であるですね物語を是非です
ね皆さんの周りにいる親しい人たちえ
愛する人たちとね共に皆さんに紡いでいっ
てほしいと思います母を失った悲しみは
消えませんけれどもでも母の畑を守り
そして母と共同著作をすることによって
ですね私はですねその悲しみと共にですね
前へ向かって前進して生きていく力を今
まさにこの瞬間この物語を語ることで母
から与えてもらっているわけなのですで私
はですね皆さんも同じようにね生きて
ほしいと思います私たちは周りの人々と
共同著作物語を共に紡ぐことで私たちなき
やと私たちの死を超えてですねまあの残さ
れた人たちの背中をそっ押すことができる
残された人たちの生きる力になることが
できる私はねそういう人に皆さんにはなっ
て欲しいなという風に思うわけなんです皆
さん人生の中でね本当に価値があることっ
て何だと思いますかそれはね何が終わるか
ではなく何が続いていくかなんですね
私たちはですね自分の泣き跡ですよその
物語の共同著作を通してですねその私たち
の死を乗り越えて他者の中でですね生き
続けることができるんですね私はですね
是非皆さんにですねそういう続いていく
存在になってほしいと思いますでそのよう
なですね存在になるためにはですね問われ
てるのは今日私たちが周りの人々にどの
ように声をかけ何を語り何を共に紡ぎ何を
一緒にし何を残していくかその1つ1つの
選択の積み重ねが私たちがどういう人に
なるかを決めていく私たちが続いていく
存在になれるかどうかを決めていくわけな
んです私は皆さんに問いたいと思います
あなたはどういう人になりたいですか選択
は今あなたの目の前にあるのです
ありがとうございまし
[拍手]
た
OG